what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
so if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so we're going to do an r tutorial today
on data visualization
with the package ggplot2 now this is not
the only visualization package
in r in fact base r before you include
any other packages has some
visualization features to it
but this is absolutely by far the most
popular visualization library in
r now i did a tutorial just a few days
ago
on deploy r and you don't necessarily
have to watch that one before this one
i'm going to try to go through this
tutorial and assume you have as little
r knowledge prior to this as possible
but i
do recommend going through and watching
that one first
just because data visualization tends to
be a little bit downstream of data
manipulation
so you need to do data manipulation and
wrangling and changing things around
oftentimes
before you have a data set that's in an
appropriate format in order for you to
visualize
so whether you're here after watching
the deployer video or not
let's get started before i do that
though
please smash the like button because
that really does help my content reach a
larger audience
also i do have a link in the description
of this video to my patreon account
so if you guys are willing to support me
there that would be massively massively
appreciated
alright so we're going to make use of
two key packages here
and those are the tidy verse and gg
theme assist
so the tidy verse is a broad set of
packages it includes dplyar it includes
gg paw 2
it includes a variety of others that are
useful and it's just really good to get
in the habit of calling the tidy verse
library
rather than all of those packages
individually and then you're going to
see gigi theme assist at the end of this
video
that's basically going to make it super
quick and easy to make
whatever kinds of themes and just
aesthetic characteristics to your graph
that you could want
so just at a high level overview of gg
plot 2 graphs
so all of them are going to include at
least three key components
and those components are number one data
number two
and aesthetic mapping and then geoms
that is objects so you just map
something to an
x into a y or something like that and
create
some kind of objects on that and you
have a basic graph
now optionally these graphs are going to
include other components like
stats that is transformations scales
facets other coordinate systems position
adjustments or themes
and we're going to go through all of
those examples in uh in this tutorial
but these three are the keys in which
any graph created through gg block 2 is
going to have
so just a little bit as a disclaimer
this code is going to be heavily adapted
from the book
r for data science by hadley wickham and
garrett grolamund
i highly recommend checking it out the
link to that is in the description of
this video
as well as in the script also the
ggplot2 cheat sheet is amazing
that's going to be linked as well and
then this script itself
if you want to follow along with it and
access it that's in my github repo
also in the description of this video
all right so we're going to start this
off by creating the most basic
and simple scatter plot that we can and
how any graph in ggplot2 is going to
come together
is you're going to start by calling the
function ggplot
and then you're going to add to it
another function which is going to begin
with the word
geom so the intuition here is we're
calling
geom point that's the function in
ggplot2 for creating a scatter plot
because the object on the graph when you
have a scatter plot
is just points across a graph and so
this is different from something like d
ply r or a lot of other tidy verse
packages
because we're using a plus here instead
of the pipe operator
but it is what it is and the data set
that we're using here
is the mpg data set that's built into
the ggplot2 package
so with this we're using ggplot with
data equals mpg
and then geom point we're going to pass
to it
this function aes this is always what
we're going to do with ggplot2
functionality
and aes that's just our aesthetic
mapping
and we're going to pass an x variable
and a y variable
so we want the variable d i s p l on the
x axis
and the variable h w y going to the
y-axis
so we do that and bam we've got
ourselves a pretty basic
not the most you know pretty looking but
a functional scatter plot
and now just one comment the data
argument and the aes
function they can go to either ggplot
or to gm point it really doesn't matter
at all if you have only one data set
and actually if you pass both of them to
geo point
that gives you a little bit more
flexibility in the event that you're
using multiple data sets and
everything's just going to one graph but
in this case here again it doesn't
really matter
now that we've got this basic scatter
plot up and running the next question
you're probably asking is well okay
that's great but now how exactly do we
make this thing look good
well it's important to understand that
the aes function takes way more
potential arguments to it
than just x and y so g on point
specifically
understands the following aesthetics
those are x
y alpha color fill group
shape size and stroke and you can see
all these things just by looking at the
help documentation
so i have that up on the bottom right
side and maybe my face is in the way so
you can't see it too
thoroughly here but if you always scroll
down
in this help documentation you're going
to be able to find the available
aesthetics that you can pass to that
to that function so one of those is
color
and let's try that one out here so first
of all just to get an understanding of
what this data set actually looks like
if you take a look here you see you have
this variable called
class so what if we make the different
classes
each have their own individual color
well what we could do
inside of the aes function is pass that
variable class
to the argument color let's run that and
bam look two seaters get their own color
compact gets their own color
etc etc so this is looking a lot better
but one thing to keep in mind here is
this is not the only way
that you can specify color we were very
specific here
to specify color inside of the aes
function but if you do it outside of the
aes
function you can manually specify what
color that you want
so i'm going to try a couple things here
at once here
to the size argument to aes i'm going to
pass the variable class
and then i'm just going to have
everything in the color blue
bam so i don't necessarily like this
kind of graph because it's hard to
visualize the graph
and get a feel for what's exactly what
but
class corresponds to a different size
and everything's blue
so again it looks better next let's see
some other examples of graphs that you
can create using ggplot2
so the next thing that i'm going to
create is a bar chart
so going down here to create a bar chart
the function that we're going to use is
geombar
and to the aes function here we're going
to pass
the variable class all we want and all
that you're really getting from a bar
chart is counts for each individual
class
and ggplot2 is automatically going to
tabulate those for us
we're going to run this and bam we have
a bar chart or
technically in this case it's
technically a column chart
what we've got here is the individual
classes on the x-axis
and then the counts on the y-axis but
you may look at this and then you say
well
i don't want the counts i want to see
the proportions
so going from a count to a proportion is
a kind of transformation
and oftentimes these kinds of stats or
transformations
are built directly into ggplot2 and we
can do them very quickly and easily
so if we add this code here instead of
just x equals class
we add y equals stat in parentheses prop
and then group equals one if we run this
all of a sudden now we have basically
the same looking bar chart or column
chart that is
but now instead of counts on the y axis
we have proportions
and i'll just scroll through these so
you can see the the bar charts look
exactly the same it's just now instead
of a count
we have a proportion and this is where
i'll be honest with you guys and let you
know
i don't always remember the exact syntax
for this kind of thing
this is one of those things though that
if you google it or even if you look on
the cheat sheet a lot of times
you will easily and quickly find this
kind of syntax
so we've covered bar charts aka column
charts in this context
the next graph that we're going to
create is a histogram
so the only real difference between a
bar chart and a histogram
is that a histogram takes a continuous
variable as its argument
so let's try this here with the function
geom underscore
histogram so here we have a histogram of
the variable
hwy and you'll see pretty quickly that
this is not the prettiest looking graph
so that's the thing you have to
configure these things quite a little
bit
inside of ggpl 2 in order to get them to
look good
so one particular argument that
geohistogram takes
is the argument been with and that's
just how
big do we want these bins you can
specify how many you want by specifying
the bins
argument but you typically aren't going
to want to do that
it's a lot more intuitive because it's
closer to what your
data actually looks like and that kind
of scale that you may be familiar with
just to specify bin width and the two
also key arguments which you'll want are
fill
and color now phil will actually specify
the real color
the color just sets the color of the
border
so let's run this we've got bin width
fill
and color in this context outside of the
aes
argument because we don't want to pass
different mappings to aes
we don't want the color to be based on
another variable
we just want to set it manually and bam
we've got this navy and gold histogram
and this looks a lot better even though
this graph looks a lot better
there are still some things to it that
i'm not a huge fan
of first of all the x-axis it
automatically has
breaks in units of 10. now it did that
automatically
even though the bin width is 5 but i
don't like this i'd rather the
axis have breaks in units of 5
and also not only does this graph not
begin at the origin
0 0 0 isn't even included
on the x-axis so we want to fix all
these things and this is a great example
to
modify the scale of this graph and so
we're going to do that by using the two
functions
scale x continuous as well as scale y
continuous and there are analogs to this
like if you had a discrete variable on
the x axis you would use
scale x discrete etc etc
but we have a continuous variable here
so there are a few
key arguments that we want to feed scale
x continuous and scale y continuous
and those are breaks limits and expand
the breaks we're going to just manually
specify what we want the breaks to be
and we're going to use the seq
that stands for sequence function to do
that and we want it to go
every five starting from zero so the seq
function would return
0 5 10 etc etc all the way to 45
we're going to do something similar to
that with the y-axis because
we want the breaks to go in units of 10
all the way up to like
90 because it looks like our max is just
over 80 here
we want the limits to be from 0 to 50 so
we want to manually specify this graph
has limits
that begin at zero and we want to
specify
we want this graph to include the origin
0 0
so this expand equals the vector c
zero zero that's just telling it
basically begin
at that point zero zero so
let's do this bam all these uh
issues are cleared up this graph begins
at the origin
both on the y-axis and the x-axis it
begins at 0
0 our limits go from 0 to 45 and our
limits go from 0 to
90. excuse me the limits go from 0 to 50
and the breaks go from 0 to 45. so this
looks
beautiful then the last graph that i'm
going to show you how to create using
ggplot2
is the box plot so with the box plot you
have to specify an x variable and a y
variable because we're basically
visualizing the distribution of one
variable
as it relates to another one so if we
create this box plot we have class on
the x-axis
and we have city that is city miles per
gallon
on the y-axis now i've specified for
this
x variable to map that to fill as well
because i want a different color for
each of these different classes as we go
from the x-axis from left to right
so this is a very visually appealing
graph
now something you're going to find
yourself wanting to do in ggplot2 pretty
often
is creating different graphs one for
each level of a different variable
now the tool for this is called facets
and we're going to use a function called
facet wrap to do this so just to show
you the variable that we're going to use
in the mpg data set
if we look up here we have this variable
called cyl
that's the cylinders of all the
individual vehicles
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to create different box plots
a set of box plots for each individual
level of the cyl
variable so we're going to use this
function
facet wrap and the syntax for this is
you're going to specify
under the argument facets the variable
that you want to
create wrappings for uh and it's going
to
be followed by this tilde symbol here
and you can specify the number of rows
and columns
and then bam we've got here a set of box
plots
for cyl equals four another set for cyl
equals five that's pretty sparse because
there's not a whole lot of five cylinder
vehicles out there
another for cyl equals six another for
cyl equals eight
so this is an incredibly powerful and
flexible way that you can create
multiple graphs all inside one single
graph
now that you see how useful facets are
let's go on to another feature of
ggplot2
and that's coordinate systems so i got
to be honest i do not use these a whole
lot because there's not a lot of
practical instances in which you'll
really need to
but probably the most common one is
chord polar
that helps you convert to polar
coordinates and then also
chord flip which we're going to see here
so in this graph we're going to start by
creating a basic bar
chart uh it's pretty easy if you see
the actual graph here but we specify
with the bar chart
we want class to go to the x-axis and
then the color of the bars is going to
be specified by the cyl
variable and we're going to add some
labels here
so we want the title of the graph to be
labeled cylinders by class
and then the color that is what's
actually going to go to the legend here
is going to be specified with uh
cylinders
so if we add chord flip to the end here
we have count on the x-axis and the
class
on the y-axis so even though we
specified class was going to go to the
x-axis
you would have seen count going to the
y-axis
but the chord flip just flips all of
that
so now we have a bar chart here instead
of a column chart
and because we specified that the fill
was going to come from the cyl variable
we have a stacked bar chart you might
not care for stack bar charts that much
though and maybe you want to see those
things side by side
so you can use another functionality
called position to change this thing
inside of ggplot2
so in our example here we're going to
run a very similar chunk of code except
we're going to add the argument
position equals dodge to all this
and now the position adjustment is not
something that i do
again in ggplot2 a whole lot because
oftentimes
i don't really need to so there are a
few different examples and you can see
all these
examples of position adjustment inside
the gg plot 2 cheat sheet
but when we specify position equals
dodge here
that's going to put these things side by
side so now these individual levels of
cylinders
they're all on top of each other or side
by side if we weren't doing the chord
flip
transformation here and we have this
kind of layout instead of just having a
stacked bar chart
so it's convenient and it'll help you
customize to get the kind of graph that
you want
and now the last thing that i'm going to
show you how to do in this tutorial is
to change the theme of the graph
now there's a default look and feel to
these ggplot2 graphs
but this is entirely customizable
so let's take a look at a graph that we
created earlier in this tutorial this is
the box plots
so you've got your standard gray
background but maybe we want to get rid
of these panel grid lines that are going
on here
let's also get rid of these axis text
that are here under
class and also let's give this thing a
labeled title put it right in the center
and make it a little bit bigger
so the code for how you would do that is
up here
but i gotta be honest sometimes it's
really hard to remember this syntax
and even though you can just run
question mark theme and get all this
syntax
it can be a little bit of a pain and
that's where gg theme assist
is an incredibly useful package so if
you have the gg theme assist package
installed and loaded then if you go up
here to add-ins
you can go to ggplot theme assistant
and what this is going to do is it's
going to open up a bit of a
guided user interface for you so you're
going to see your graph
up here above here and there are a
variety of things that we can basically
go through and change here
so the grid major and the grid minor
lines
i want to get rid of them we're going to
set those to blank
bam you can see these things changing on
the graph here
you can go over here to settings and you
can change the width and the height of
the graph
you can go over here to access and then
then you can change the axis
text on both the x and the y axis
as well as just some overall features
like the family
face size and things like that i
mentioned i want to get rid of these
little axis
ticks so let's set that to blank bam
we see those have disappeared and i
wanted to modify the title
now if we go over here you can specify a
title here i'm just going to call it box
plot example
then for the face here i'm going to
change that to bold because i want that
to stick out
i want to make that a little bit bigger
and then under h just here we're going
to set that to 0.5
so that it's centered bam
we do that we hit done
and then would you look at that so
ggplot theme assistant
automatically wrote all the code in
order to do this
so if we just run this here guess what
we have reproducible code
and would you look at that now ggplot2
is an incredibly flexible and powerful
package
and to be honest newcomers to r can kind
of struggle with this package at first
just because the syntax to it can be
kind of weird
and there's so much that you can do with
this package
so i strongly recommend going to the
cheat sheet
figuring out where everything is and
then just taking some time to run
through some of the examples on that
cheat sheet
once you've figured out the intuition
and the feel and the syntax for ggplot2
you're going to be amazed how quickly
and how easily
you can create really good looking
graphs and it's honestly going to be a
huge
motivator for you if you're just getting
started with r for the first time
so thanks for watching this tutorial if
you found it helpful
please consider sharing it also once
again smash the like button
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard non-data